Sarah Palin is running for a House of
Representative seat representing Alaska
she's the former mayor of Wasilla the
former partial term governor of Alaska
and former vice presidential running
mate back in 2008 you might remember she
quit being governor before the end of
her term and she is essentially giving
up and if I didn't think she was such a
disaster for the country I might feel a
little bit bad for her but I don't Sarah
Palin appeared on Steve bannon's the war
room and she said there you know what
I'm no longer accepting donations I've
gotten rid of my campaign stuff staff
because they gave me bad advice let me
interpret this for you Sarah Palin has
given up she's trying to save money
because it would be pointless to keep
spending money because she's obviously
going to lose but look at the spin I
didn't know what way was up and down
after I heard this the first time I'm
gonna get in trouble for saying this but
sometimes you wonder the people who are
actually advising working on campaigns
you gotta wonder if they're really in it
for the right reasons because sometimes
they give really crappy advice and
effort so I'm doing a lot of this myself
I'm not going to ask people for
donations though which ticks off those
in my campaign who and other campaigns
you know because they look at this as a
business and they get a cut of funds
raised I don't ask people for money
because I've won all the races that I've
been in over my life except one
um the big one and uh I've done it being
outspent ten to one or whatever it is
because
he'll be outspent 10-0 now I roll and
it's always worked well
yeah and you can tell from the look on
Steve bannon's face
it's over for Sarah Palin what this
means is nobody is supporting me anymore
I'm out of money no one's donating
anyway so I'll say I'm no longer
accepting donations as we talked about
last week Republican Alaska Senator Lisa
murkowski is voting for Sarah Palin's
Democratic opponent people don't like
that Sarah Palin quit being Governor a
lot of Republicans in Alaska
don't like Sarah Palin and this is just
the last nail in the coffin I'm no
longer having any staff
and I'm no longer accepting donations
you're giving up Sarah you're giving up
and my hope is and I don't know if this
will be the case
My Hope
is that this will really be the end of
Sarah Palin's political career a career
that never really should have gotten
started but it did
um and she is really in a in a sense a
precursor to the trumpism that exists
today Palin giving up and it is yet
another humiliation
you already know that you need a VPN to
protect your privacy from your internet
provider from Tech platforms from
hackers and you've seen a ton of ads for
different vpns they seem similar which
one do you choose there's really one
thing I look at can it be independently
verified that the VPN isn't logging your
activity that's why when we were looking
for a VPN sponsor we reached out to
private internet access because private
internet access is the only VPN with a
no log policy that has been proven in
court not once but multiple times their
VPN is 100 open source the code is
public their server networks and
management systems are independently
audited by Deloitte to verify there is
no logging with their new next-gen
server setup it's also one of the only
vpns fast enough for stream gaming and
other activities my audience gets
private internet access for 82 percent
off that's just two dollars and eleven
cents a month plus three months free go
to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link is down
below